dawn of the Planet of the Apes on the
disaster scale of disaster likelihood
how likely is an ape take over a drug be
given to apes that would change them
physiologically and mentally it's not
very likely I would say impossible one
can really get off but wait didn't we
evolve from apes and we didn't just stop
evolving when we became human so aren't
smart dates inevitable so we didn't
evolve from chimpanzees we didn't evolve
from anything that's around right now
everything that's around right now
shares a common ancestor in the ancient
past next you're gonna tell me they can
never talk humans developed language and
to develop language what we did is to
lower where our vocal cords are
chimpanzees have the same sort of
structure we presume our ancestor had
and their vocal cords cannot produce
language in the same way that we can
they'll never learn how to talk what
else in the movie they show individuals
from the different species together so
male orangutan with male gorillas and
now chimpanzees male gorillas don't like
being around other males male orangutan
don't like being around other males
that's unlikely to happen
so it's not probable but it is possible
if you learned anything in the video
make sure to share it and make sure to
subscribe to the wired Channel